hello there welcome back today we are
covering the events of Marvel Spider-Man
Miles Morales we covered Peter's journey
in the last video be sure to watch that
one before this one too anyway there's a
lot to get through so let's do this
there is a second Spider-Man in New York
City during the devil's breath crisis
Miles Morales went through many
lifechanging events his father Jeff was
lost during a criminal attack led by
Martin Lee aka Mr a negative and
something Monumental happened too thanks
to a mysterious spider bite fresh out of
an OS Corp lab Miles Morales developed
Spider-Man likee powers and after
revealing them to Peter Parker he agreed
to train him to be the next Spider-Man
we pick up the story 10 months later
it's Christmas time in New York and
Miles returns home as the snow begins to
settle on the ground mm is a typical
teen trying to fit in where he can and
being awkward around the girl he has a
crush on so awkward Sor miles and his
mother Rio have moved from Brooklyn to
Harlem to make a new start but all this
scene setting is interrupted by a text
from the OG Spider-Man a police Convoy
needs protecting and miles is already on
his way though his swinging is a little
suspect this Spider-Man is still very
green with much to learn the cable
supporting the raft prisoner snaps and
Miles attempts to fix the issue and
accidentally freeze a super
villain Rhino is loose and the big man
takes the Spider-Man on a journey
they'll never forget and J Jonah Jameson
too find it hey Jonah looking good very
fast Menace effectless treacherous
unhinged Menace this version of rhino
somehow has the edge over Spider-Man
Peter needs miles to step up and all my
word he does that and something
unexpected
happens miles unleashes his new power
bio electricity Rhino doesn't stand a
chance and is defeated Miles Morales has
saved Peter Parker an important
character arrives to the scene with an
overpowered security Force this is Simon
creger of the roxon energy corporation
who has a new form of clean energy and
that's the focus of this entire story
this new form of energy is cleverly
named new form genius PR work there and
this stuff has the potential of powering
entire districts of New York something
strange occurs next roxon agree to keep
Rhino subdued while the police arrive
and our Spider-Man agree to it a
decision they'll come to regret with
that out of the way Peter has news he's
going to simaria with Mary Jane to cover
a story over there I'm not going to be
around for the next few weeks somehow
Spider-Man and silver Sable became
friends during the city that never
sleeps DLC which I'll be covering in the
next video right now Peter is embracing
photography again after losing his job
with Dr Octavius he's at a Crossroads in
his life while Peter is away miles will
be the only Spider-Man in New New York
City he's going solo after 10 months of
training I promise to do everything in
my power to protect this
city I promise Peter leaves miles a gift
which he opens with his best friend geni
miles officially has his own super suit
complete with knee and elbow pads and it
looks like this miles wears Adidas kicks
oh and even though Peter isn't around he
still finds a way to teach his Protege
using augmented reality because yes
science roxon have built a new Plaza
which will also house one of their new
energy reactors fit to safely fuel the
surrounding Burrows this is also the
location we find a new group of enemies
attempting to steal information about
that new form reactor Meet The
Underground a high-tech militant group
with an unknown agenda but those snazzy
weapons can't compete with miles's new
powers roxs on Plaza is safe and the
police take over as it's Christmas Eve
miles rushes home to spend time with his
mom Rio who so happens to be running for
city council also here is geni a School
mate and best friend of miles and
another special guest arrives it's so
good to see you how are you it's been
like months this is Finn Mason miles's
other best friend from childhood she is
extremely intelligent and we learn about
her through flashbacks Finn is freshly
back in New York City and miles is
surrounded by the people he loves yet a
hole Still Remains we miss you Jeff geni
already knows his friend's secret
identity and builds a mobile phone app
to allow the public to directly request
help from Spider-Man and his first
assignment comes through from Aaron
Davis wait what that's my uncle does he
know you're Spider-Man no it's miles's
Uncle miles works with Aaron to stand up
against the underground to fix the train
tracks and in return for this help Aaron
gives Spider-Man a rail pass for his
efforts how did you don't worry I won't
tell you Mom this Uncle knows his nephew
well but his secret is safe outside of
story missions miles spends most of his
time in Harlem helping his neighbors
this story revolves around Harlem and
the community there from the local Feast
kitchens to store owners and one
Adventure has miles saving the city's
other Spider-Man no not that one this
one Spider-Man the cat Harlem is all
kinds of weird
Spider-Man one thing we can guarantee in
this universe any wholesome Moment Like
This is usually followed by something
going very wrong and this time it's
during a rally for real Morales and her
push for City Hall The Underground crash
the party with their leader the tinkerer
and the first of many many battles
between the underground and roxon
begin suddenly an explosion is heard
across the city this was a diversion the
real event is on the bridge the
underground are here for one thing Rox
On's new form energy canisters quick as
a flash miles attempts to take back the
new form but his bio El electricity
mixes with the technology of the
tinkerer
what are you
doing the tinkerer is Finn she smashes
miles into the remaining new Farm
canisters exploding that volatile
compound he's destabilizing it get
down which means there is only one last
canister of new form which the tinkerer
Steals and takes away while Spider-Man
here casually holds together a falling
bridge and saves everyone in sight
here's the confusing part miles is not
regarded as a hero by the rocks on
soldiers instead they are ordered to
take him
out what the hell where'd he go miles
has yet another new power invisibility
after escaping we are left unsure who
the bad guys really are here his best
friend Finn and the underground or sign
Simon creger and roxon things are
getting serious so Miles and bezzy mate
geni design a new high-tech suit capable
of being a conduit for the bioelectric
powers miles now has this Spider-Man has
shed his skin and is becoming his own
man miles does some super sleuthing
visiting Finn's old digs and discovers
recordings made by her and her brother
Rick it's revealed that the new form
project is not as safe as roxson is
making out in fact it's causing people
close to it to fall ill or worse
Rick here worked for roxon until he
realized that his work was causing these
issues and makes a vow to destroy the
research without me they'll have no idea
how new form Works project will be DOA
I'll record us things go wrong video
uploads straight to the bugle perfect
miles then casually breaks into rocks on
HQ to find more answers yet a familiar
face meets
him what's so funny damn miles we're a
skinny ass kid you hit hard uncle Aaron
not only is Finn the tinkerer but
miles's own uncle is the super villain
the prowler miles refuses to leave so
Uncle Aaron begrudgingly agrees to help
him and it's worth it the pair find the
final recording of Rick and Finn you've
seen me lately
right let's make the world safer
3 2
man that wasn't me industrial sabotage
Rick
really Rick down
no
over Rick sacrificed himself to stop the
new form project but it was futile Simon
ker was waiting ready for this miles now
knows who the real enemy is and uses his
crazy electrical powers to absorb a
reactor core only
H what are you
doing Spider-Man can barely walk after
doing this but somehow he keeps the
energy
safe M talk to me kid you all right the
unlikely Duo escape and what looks like
a heart-to- heart between family members
is actually Aaron manipulating miles he
just doesn't see it yet tell her you
want to join the underground you just
told me don't take off the mask don't
tell her you Spider-Man go to her as a
friend outside of their alter OS miles
meets up with Finn for coffee and hints
about joining the underground if you
want my help I'm all in it's as subtle
as a brush but it works miles has joined
the team he's part of the underground
and he's trusted so much that Finn takes
him immediately to their headquarters
result mm then finds the underground's
makeshift reactor and uncovers their
plan Finn the tinkerer plans to blow up
the rocks on Plaza using its own power
source to prevent this our Spider-Man
attempt to take the final canister of
new form but the underground have
upgraded their new weapons are designed
to fight miles after an epic Chase and
fight scene the tinkerer has the upper
Edge give me one good reason not to end
you my mom would be very
upset
miles
Finn disappears and miles is unable to
follow days pass and Miles returns to
helping his community like pulling this
mil out of a car boot or trunk whichever
you prefer Harlem Loves this Spider-Man
which includes Haley even as Spider-Man
Miles can't hide his Crush for her my
guy learned sign language just to talk
to this girl dedication the prowler AKA
uncle Aaron gets back in touch with
Spider-Man aka miles and continues
manipulating him to uncover information
about the tinkerer AKA Finn there's a
lot going on here yet there is a
definite real bond between the two
sharing memories about Jeff and growing
up together work life balance kid most
important thing miles eventually meets
back up with Finn to talk things through
and a solution looks imminent then roxon
crashed the party with a new and
improved Rhino heading the team
unprepared and outnumbered roxs on take
both of the friends down the duo wake up
and interrogated by Simon creger he
wants that last canister of new form
back and as a threat he hints at using
miles as a laborat to understand his
bioelectrical powers is
I'm wow miles is then beaten to a pulp
by roxson soldiers so much so that
another power is Unearthed the mega
Venom
blast Spider-Man and the tinkerer put
aside their differences and find an
Escape Route during their Journey a
conversation is overheard you agreed to
leave the kid alone uncle Aaron the
prowler miles's own Uncle set him up in
order to capture the tinkerer but crego
went back on his word to keep miles safe
and if Aaron went to the cops about it
he'd be arrested too he's stuck between
a rock and a hard place miles and Finn
make it to the exit and have an Almighty
face off with the new and improved Rhino
using his own size and weight against
him to become Victorious but their truce
is about to end as Finn attempts to un
alive Rhino miles is not about that kind
of life and stops
her and now Finn isn't happy again screw
up the bridge Destro my lab come near me
again I'll kill you miles is so beaten
and bruised he can barely walk and he
dragged home by geni and in walks
mom I have to tell you do something
we've made it to the end of this tale
miles must stop his best friend Finn
from accidentally blowing up half the
city and oh oh no there's one more
thing sorry about this nephew the
prowler attempts to imprison Spider-Man
not out of spite or Revenge but to
Simply keep his nephew safe of course
miles's morals won't allow that so they
beat the crap out of each other for a
while I know I messed up
doesn't have to be like this I can't
turn my back when people need me okay
this time it really is the end miles
joins forces with his uncle and fights
through waves of roxon and underground
soldiers to set up the final Faceoff at
roxon Plaza but alas it's already too
late the last canister is installed this
can no longer be stopped the entire
battle between best friends is futile
the pair will be vaporized in a matter
of
minutes
[Applause]
I'm sorry it's
okay there is one final chance if miles
can make it to the reactor maybe he
could absorb the
energy
I can't hold this in much
longer
[Music]
I can't it's okay can't just let
go let
go
no no no no no
please
my oh
God say something is
everyone okay we're safe all of us it's
over Harlem is saved but Finn is lost
forever in a touching moment the
community see who their Spider-Man
savior is and unite to protect his IDE
identity you did good
Spider-Man
thanks we jump forward four weeks and
things are looking better the prowler
turned himself in and took down Simon
creger and the rocksong corporation in
the process miles is totally fine with
his uncle being in prison and he's
actually become quite a confident young
man who dances like nobody is watching
and look who's back it's Peter Parker
he's returned from simaria to show how
much miles has improved over the last
month it's now him drinking a hot
beverage upside down just like his
mentor Peter signaling that miles is no
longer a trainee he's the real deal I'm
Adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next
[Music]
time